détroit 3 enfants et mon mari était
percé c'est une blessure vieille de 40
ans encore douloureuse entre 1975 et
deux millions de cambodgiens sont morts
un cinquième de la population exterminer
victimes de la dictature khmers rouges
t la ville à la villa en gros la cause
le régime communiste qu'instaurer polpot
prison tortures exécutions le despote a
mis en place une machine à tuer son
projet éliminer les instruits et
rééduquer les machines et très pour
créer une société 9 en 1979 fin de la
dictature et début d'une longue
cicatrisation pour se reconstruire la
société fait un travail de mémoire des
lieux de détention sont ouverts au
public comme le camp s 21
les appareils de torture
les photos des détenus leur crâne la
mémoire mais aussi la justice pour
panser les plaies du génocide faut
l'enterrer d'ajout de l'humanité on ne
va pas tolérer certaines ce crime l'a77
génocide là parce que faris auprès d'eux
le dernier et des idées à d'autres
sociétés à août mais il y a eu un procès
au vietnam tout de suite après les faits
mais la plupart des responsables n'ont
pas été jugés polpot lui-même à échapper
à la justice
jusqu'à sa mort en 1998
en 2005 un procès parrainé par l'onu est
annoncée pour l'année suivante dans un
pays qui n'a pas encore fait de deuil
les gens qui vont être jugés pour moi
sont les exécutants
maintenant il faut penser aux la
business pour moi ce procès est très
important vous ramener la réconciliation
et la justice au congo tient au coeur de
ce procès cet homme duk directeur de la
prison s 21
quinze mille personnes y ont été
torturées et exécutées en 2010
l'audience est suivi dans tout le pays
doug est condamné à 30 ans de prison
pas assez pour cette femme la fille
d'une victime qui aurait dû être
condamné à la prison à vie en 2012 duke
est finalement condamné à perpétuité en
appel
un symbole fort pour la nation en 2018
les deux derniers grands dirigeants
khmers ont été déclarés coupables de
génocide
le mot est enfin lâché quarante ans
après les faits reconnus par la
communauté internationale
[Musique]